[Music]
[Music]
so what are you doing right now i'm
attempting crepes
but this one came out pretty bad and in
my defense though you just started
recording and i already made all of
these
look at these these look good but it was
beautiful
i got camera shy i guess and that was
the first crepe that came out once we
started
filming it still looks good what are you
talking about what is this
that's not it's not a good creature it's
negligible you know we always we all
just eat the food and it all comes out
the same so
yeah but does it matter presentation
matters aren't you the chef in this
house
true no i i if i was making it i'd
probably say the same thing too but
i'm just being nice oh that's sweet i
love you
love you too can i take a peek at these
though these look really amazing i like
the steam okay
okay okay okay yeah there's like steam
coming out so look
um i recently bought this thingamabob
which
is a cool item that you can create the
batter inside of this so you don't have
to like get a mixing bowl because
there's like a whisk ball in there so i
just whisk it up create the
crepe mix i bought this crepe supplies
and i also bought a waffle maker so
we've been making waffles recently
nice oh
[Music]
even though it's lunch time we're about
to eat some crepes because isaac
is now home he walked to school and
walked home from school for the very
first time
yesterday was his very first day back to
in person school after an entire year of
pandemic so i actually interviewed him
yesterday when we brought him home from
school
so insert interview now so tell me what
it was like
your first day back after a whole year
of pandemic and
starting seventh grade in a brand new
school it was pretty uh
it was pretty nerve-wracking but after
uh
i went there the nerve rack went away i
walked up to the ramp got
me going to my class they checked my
temperature
and um yeah and then i went to my first
period which was math
i guess the only interesting part about
it was
me going in with the mask like it was my
first time being
at the school so i wasn't familiar with
with anything so i
ask people yeah because i know leading
up to this
you were really dreading it and now that
you've experienced your first day
like what would you tell isaac from the
past
um your first day isn't gonna be that
bad
it was really cute seeing him all
nervous when like going into
school but then when he got picked up he
was like
so relaxed so happy and like really glad
that he's back into school because he
was fighting me
but after having that interview he was
really happy yeah he woke up early today
and went to school early and everything
too
like he's like excited to go now excited
which is so cute and it's also the first
time
so in his last school from second grade
to sixth grade it was the same school so
usually and then that school actually
went all the way up to eighth grade
so in terms of like the layout of the
school it
feels like an elementary school it
doesn't feel like the middle school this
school though it's only six seven eight
so it's only middle school kids so it's
more of that middle school experience
and so i can see him really enjoying it
it's really awesome seeing my kids so
big and then he just walked in recently
like right before we started filming he
walked in and he was all happy
like hello family i'm home he's so cute
yeah that's why we're making him crepes
as a
mini celebration and then after this i
have to go shoot
with the big mud girls it's just one
episode so i'll be back and then we can
continue our day
[Music]
skills ah don't jinx me oh sorry
ah yeah this is a fail buddy you're so
cute
i can't do this when the camera's on i
was killing it right when i was off
why it's just like so smackable
[Music]
all right so i've been on the hunt for a
new camera i can't hear myself so i've
been on the hunt for a new camera for a
while now there was a time when i loved
cameras and i used to shoot on a canon
5d mark
iii and i love cinematography i love cam
mopping i love
getting really really cool shots
somewhere along the way
i got burned out on cameras and i guess
for the sake of
vlogging you don't need a high-end
camera so
i've been using a lot of these
point-and-shoot cameras ironically
enough i'm actually starting to burn out
on these point-and-shoot cameras and
i've been
itching to get a cinema camera stuck
between a sony a7iii
or sony a7c or a sony fx3
which camera should i get all right so
just finished editing for the day
and uh tiff is on her way home got a
package that came in earlier today and
i'm gonna greet her with it see her
reaction to it
tiff is
delicioso so we just got a packaging
today yeah
it is a new hoover smartwash carpet
cleaner
automatic carpet cleaner so shout outs
to hoover for sponsoring today's video
we've had cats for eight years and the
cats have done
a number on the past couple places we
lived at
at the apartment and at this new house
we've been pretty good
about cleaning after them staying on top
of the carpet but
eventually there's gonna be that one
little accident that's gonna happen and
we're gonna be like oh no we need a
carpet cleaner
we finally got our own carpet cleaner
here at the house and i'm super excited
to use it i know i was so excited when
hoover hit us up and they were like hey
you just want to partner like yes
we've been needing a carpet cleaner for
many many years especially
this guy look at him he's trying to get
out he knows we're talking
so this guy as you guys know because
i've complained about it
a million times he look at look at him
kicking my face
he poops on our brand new couch yeah
that's why we have uh all our pillows
lined up right here
protect the couch and then he loves
especially loves this corner here for
some reason
and that's where he was pooping yeah
it's like he's trying to leave you a
present
[Music]
and then
when we are not in our bedroom we have
to have the door closed
because he will sneak in and so we're
constantly having to wash our sheets and
stuff
but not just this guy this guy's not the
only problem
your sister is a problem too huh so maya
she vomits everywhere she throws up and
just this morning
oh yeah literally this this hoover
smart wash pet complete automatic carpet
cleaner could not have come
at a more perfect time this morning look
at what maya did
she threw up right here yucky dry cat
food throw up
i'm super super super happy that this
baby came in today
let's clean this closet
[Music]
oh and we got an extra long
dang whoever does that play around they
give you all the gadgets you need
perfect for our last house because we
have yeah stairs
man that was a pain in the butt with
these cats we had so many stains that we
need to get rid of
lost a bit of our deposit on that we
definitely did
any help no
independent woman you got it baby
[Laughter]
nice you did it i never doubted you
[Music]
[Applause]
this thing is supposed to be super easy
to use that's the reason why out of all
their models that they
had this is the one i was the most
excited for especially because of this
spot chaser one
so i'm talking about it already so it
already has batteries in it and i
already pulled the tab so it should be
working
so i'm going to be pre-treating this
throw up stain
let's see how it works
oh cool
with normal carpet cleaners there's
always a trigger release if you guys
have ever rented one
you know exactly what i'm talking about
because i've used them in the past and
oh my god it's so
it hurts your hand to hold on to the
trigger to release the solution
as you're trying to clean right and
there's also like you're never
sure if you're using too much solution
or not enough but this
baby here is all automatic so all i have
to do
is turn it on and when i move forward
it'll be cleaning and when i pull back
it actually dries it so it's like an
all-in-one thing here so let's see
[Music]
dude that's magic where'd it go it's
gone
okay this is as easy as using a vacuum i
need to do the rest of this rug
okay so all right moving out of the way
tiff is in her happy place right now
this is her happy place
dang look at all that dirty water wow
it is dark now i really want to clean
all of upstairs
we've activated the cleaning monster in
tiff she will not stop now you've lost
her
for the rest of the night look at all
this ew
yucky this is our entryway rug too so
it's always getting a lot of traffic on
a lot of traffic this
oh man it's gonna be fun okay after
using this
for the first time and seeing how it
completely disappeared this thing like
where is it try pointing it out
i highly recommend the smart wash pet
complete automatic carpet cleaner by
hoover so if you guys want to get your
own you can check out our link in the
description but
anyway let's go back to these cats okay
this little boy
he is now eight years old yesterday or
two days ago
two days ago him and maya's birthday
they finally turned eight years old
casey and i were just looking on our
instagram reminiscing on when we got
them
they were born because we don't know the
exact date so it's either april 11th or
april
april 12th and i think some years we
celebrate it on the 11th and then some
years we celebrate on the 12th it's
funny because april 12th is joe's
birthday so sometimes they
celebrate their birthday on the same day
yeah so we don't know the exact day they
were born
but we found them on instagram like i
found them on instagram i clicked on the
on the hashtag adopt a kitten and then i
just so happened to find a photo of a
litter
there was this girl who was volunteering
at a veterinary
clinic so i sent her a message i was
like hey i'm interested in a cat like
do you have any info and then i was also
kind of pressing my fingers kind of like
she could be literally
across the world like who knows right
because this is instagram but luckily
she was
in the neighborhood like in the area of
la so she
told me that she would get me in contact
with the man who brought in the kittens
to get checked and then when we
contacted him we went to go
see and initially we were just gonna get
one but then this guy so he had six and
he was like come on like
you don't want them to be alone like you
want them to have a companion after like
talking
with casey i'm like oh my god yeah he's
right like we don't want him to be all
lonely should we get two so then in that
very moment we decided to get two cats
but it was still too soon for them to
leave their mom we were like okay
we picked out a great kitten and a brown
kitten
and um and it was funny because there
was two brown kitties who looked
identical so who knows if maya's the
one that we initially picked because
they could we could have mixed them up
but zoe was for sure zou because he was
the only great cat that had a tail
the other cat grey cat that was in the
litter didn't have a tail so i ended up
picking
zoe with the tail and then so we waited
three weeks
and then we went back to pick them up
and we've had them ever since
and that was like may of 2013 until
today so yeah it's just so crazy seeing
them
grow for these past eight years and then
having them be part of our family it's
so
interesting to get to know their
personalities
and their quirks and it's just been
a real treat having them in our family i
always feel like
in some essence like they're they kind
of like cemented our relationship
together too
it was like our one year in and we were
like let's let's get some cats you know
let's get domesticated together
you know our little kids and our little
children yeah we ended up moving in
together december of 2012.
we got them we went to go see them in
april late april 2013. so it was like a
few months in and then
like they've been with us pretty much as
long as we've
almost as long as we've lived together
yeah and then it was cute because
as i was looking at our instagram or my
instagram
checking out their hashtag because i
made them a hashtag zoe maya
and then i found a video of isaac
and he was five years old and he grabbed
my phone i think it was on vine that he
did this video oh
just insert now hi road ma um
my name is eisen hi um
these are my cats these are my cats joe
and mario
um bye prince isaac
hey hey what's up what's up who did i
wake you up no
okay all right all right cool cool cool
how low can your voice go you don't know
it's so low that it doesn't sound like a
voice anymore now it sounds like a
whisper
yeah it doesn't do you remember vlogging
about the cats
like a long long long time ago when
you're five years old
and that clip you made yeah actually
yeah like this is my cats and stuff
yeah you should redo that
and your voice is so different from that
video what happened
[Music]
oh there goes the machine
tiff is cleaning for the rest of the
night i guarantee it
how you like it i love it
it's really dry now because i didn't
notice that there's a dry only option
too
oh crazy she's a cleaning maniac
cleaning maniac
[Music]
hmm